deux mois après sa réélection l'appel
des manuels macro français lui donner
une majorité forte n'a pas été entendu
le chef d'état arrivent en tête au
second tour des élections législatives
mais très loin de la majorité absolue
qu'il souhaitait du tout jean luc
mélenchon a gagné son pari est réussi à
placer l'alliance des partis de la
gauche appelait nul en la première force
d'opposition c'est une situation
totalement inattendu absolument inouïe
la déroute du parti présidentiel est
totale et autres majoritaires
nous avons réussi
l'objectif politique que nous étions
donné tu va croquer n'a plus ni la
majorité absolue ni la majorité relative
et bien il ne va pas pouvoir passer ses
réformes telles qu'il entend par ce que
nous serons là et nos députés seront là
pour cela comment peut-on dire est que
penser de tous les efforts qu'on a faits
sur le terrain et
se crée aujourd'hui on est la première
force d'opposition à l'assemblée
nationale c'est historique
entre surprises la percée considérable
du rassemblement national vive la
république telle avance de partis de
l'extrême droite multiplient parquet son
nombre de députés
une première depuis plus de 35 ans nous
incarnerons une opposition ferme c'est à
dire sans connivence mais une opposition
responsable
c'est à dire respectueuse des
institutions est toujours constructif
parce que notre seul et unique boussole
est l'intérêt de la france et du peuple
français ces élections législatives ont
encore une fois été boudée par les
français le taux d'abstention devrait
atteindre près de 54% ici marie michel
lauzon radio canada montréal